oh hey how's it going my name is Pierre
fat welcome back time to drive my bangs
roof elastic I'm shut up but hey I you
do with nice Swedish ah yes yes ah ah oh
we're gonna die down here we're gonna
die down here
I gonna die yet out here gonna die down
here stop blinking stop blinking that's
fine
you [ __ ] barrels I can't do anything
well at least she had potatoes you know
what at least she had potatoes
Oh God
ah
that thing is not pretty
Oh
Oh what the [ __ ] is that thing like a
gorilla piggy Oh awesome
okay okay it's gonna be okay
everything's gonna be all right yes
their main comfort
another rat gangbang Rama Dane as I like
to call it gang a rang over back here
wonderful
hey friends work ye okay yeah you're not
really my friend dog oh where are we
nice
water in his shoes always the water and
the sparks of the embers of the wheels
is too bony it's too damn phony
that's what she said
hello hi I bit there these men professor
these so-called men of vision they would
shackle the masses to a wheel and turn
it to their backs break rules are an
opiate the law from these fools who
Lackey
these priests these officials this
government
you can't Shippuden mother promise of a
better world for these unfortunates in
the work houses in the orphanages that
believe in heaven is surely the only
sucker one can find we do not need to
wait we can bring forth paradise now we
can speed the passion with only a small
sacrifice we can fold the apocalypse
with just a small sacrifice we can free
our shackles and deliver them to
paradise now can I guess that guy is
crazy one
number here
I don't like this place not a big fan of
this place would love to get the [ __ ]
out of this place whatever guy some kind
of puzzle well what is going I guess we
need number two huh go ah go
take the coal singing the mining song
singing abiding song all night and let's
click on the animal
magnificent let's go to the control room
I guess
three and five
okay there's a lot more than I thought
or it's all good
sex wasn't on so I guess we gotta fix it
god dammit
five is on is everyone on oh hey hey
that's a pot in the USA
wonderful
alright all machine sounds like that
stop are you are your furnaces no
they're not
thanks machine we only need six yeah
it's only six but we need more coal for
it but supposed coal it's awesome
alright Mac sent a pic reply epoca
wonderful
yo yo yo I hate him I hate him with a
fashion passion whatever okay Industrial
agony she ate the putter flexes clueper
yes
and then initiate the drama magic stunk
penetrate the big [ __ ]
and turn off the nipples with did it
what the hell did I do
I don't know what I did but I regret it
already
all right I'd are like whoa
I don't wanna
we're going deeper in the serious
[ __ ] hellhole
what what oh great no no no no that's
fine everything is so great I'm a
rainbow
all good in the hood all got in the hood
I'll get in the hood I'll go to the head
it's all good in the head all good in
the hood the hood it's all good because
it's all good in the hood
you [ __ ] bird breed what house I mean
anyway
I just wanna kind of simply Adam this
place not oh oh oh oh oh oh we made it
mainly you [ __ ] up gross that was out
on me
it's a stroll in the park it's a stroll
and apart
it's a stroll in the park
we are strolling in the park
you idiot
I don't like this I do not like this
where are we what am I doing with my
life I'm sorry
I'm so sorry I'm very sorry I'm sorry
just leave me alone play play
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh oh we're jumping we jumping jump up
ma'am again Bop hold your hand out and
reach it up
let us see what you are playing it all
back to you
oh hey hey
which are bloody Helvetica defeat the
butler a sodahead a fish a bleak
Yolo yo to the O to the PO to the pros
yes yes yes I am the smartest
[ __ ]
what this [ __ ] planet Oh
okay yes yes baby sexist Texas Duckman
and YouTube the cast of that only brings
on sing love what's up with your ways
down my pants and I bet you feel nuts
he says oh we go in there yes why not
everything is great Oh everythingís are
great like that that's great
oh my god it's great it oh my god
great great you know what let's go up
here
alright [ __ ] great
yup that's great too I have a goddamn
doors lock daunting
wait a second this is our escape this is
our chance to get out of the hellhole oh
my god I am so smart where is my genius
award I have like five of them actually
please don't send me more of them I was
a joke
wonderful wonderful this is great oh
yeah big fan of those noises I like them
on Facebook
oh I knew I shouldn't have that extra
taco
all right
that's an episode hope you enjoyed the
Kamaka to dead hit subscribe comment
resident and I'll see you in the next
episode